a lot of american businesses are trying
to figure out okay i've got more than
100 employees
what am i going to do
am i going to require the the vaccine
let's talk to one business guy ben
shapiro is the host of the bench bureau
show he's also the editor emeritus of
the daily wire
ben uh your company's got over a hundred
employees so what are you gonna do are
you gonna listen to the president
everywhere everybody gonna roll up their
sleeves or are you gonna take a
different approach
uh of course not we're gonna use every
method and uh and resource at our
disposal to defy the president's
unconstitutional order and this is
coming from somebody who's very
pro-vaccine i was vaccinated as soon as
possible i've encouraged everybody to
get the vaccine or pretty much everybody
to get the vaccine and the notion that
the federal government has the ability
to force every business in america with
over 100 employees by the way i'm not
sure why it's over 100 employees
theoretically it should be every
business in america because you can get
infected anywhere right but every
business in america with over 100
employees to either force its employees
to vaccinate or force them to test every
week or fire them presumably
he said he came into office saying i'm
not going to shut down the economy i'm
not going to shut down the country i'm
going to shut down the virus he failed
to shut down the virus so now he's going
to shut down the economy in the country
apparently well ben uh they say that he
says joe biden businesses who refuse
will be fined 14 000
per violation your ceo said that you
will you will use legal action to resist
in a tweet are you prepared for this
uh we are i mean we are staffing up
right now on the legal side we are
already getting any lawsuit ready that
needs to be gotten ready we have to see
the actual regulations know the details
of that lawsuit what we can tell you is
that the provisions that joe biden is
going to be citing under osha are wildly
overbought and frankly i think that he's
made a huge tactical legal blunder here
i think there's every possibility that
something like this goes to the supreme
court level and suddenly we see a
complete rewriting of the administrative
state because joe biden couldn't get his
act in order and so he decided to issue
a tyrannical and authoritarian order
here also you had an interesting tweet
uh which is getting a lot of news when
you said maybe if he found if we fi we
tell joe biden that the taliban isn't
vaccinated he'll get just as mad at them
does it astound you in all seriousness
that his anger is look is is focused on
the unvaccinated in america as small
percentages that is and not on the
terrorist regime that has taken over a
country and the embarrassment that he's
caused our nation
we're not even a year into this
presidency and this is a failed
president on every level and so he's
attempting to redirect all of the ire at
his presidency at your fellow americans
you're supposed to be angry or neighbor
for unvaccinating if you're vaccinated
even though joe biden himself yesterday
said that your unvaccinated neighbor
effectively poses no threat to you
instead joe biden wants you to be angry
at that neighbor as opposed to him
here's the reality if you don't like
lockdowns if you don't like mandates
look at the person who's attempting to
issue the lockdown and the mandates the
person who's attempting to control
american business top down who's
attempting to control every school in
america top down maybe you should direct
your ira at that person not the person
living next door
speaking of next door you used to live
in california you have since moved
to a
a freer state than that a lower tax date
as well i wanted you to weigh in on the
fact that coming up next week they're
going to have the recall election of
gavin newsom in california he very
famously pretty much locked down all of
california larry elder is surging in the
polls uh but he was essentially accosted
uh let's see it would have been on
wednesday venice beach where a woman
screen right in a gorilla mask with a
pink wig
tries to hit him in the head with an egg
watch this
what's your reaction here's larry elder
last night on tucker watch
she might be one of the 20 000 people
that were released early uh from our
prisons felons many of whom were violent
offenders under this governor you know
if i were a democrat obviously uh this
would be called systemic racism they'd
be calling it a hate crime i don't like
to play that game i knew do know this
there was a big article about me a
negative in the new york times never
once mentioned that i'm black never
wanted men to mention that i would be
the first black governor of california i
never made a big deal out about that i
don't want people to vote for me or
against me because i'm black but on the
very same page of the new york times
there was a big article about the quote
first female governor of new york close
quote even though she didn't get elected
she was basically appointed because the
other governor resigned so they cared
about the first when it was a female
democrat but couldn't give a rip about
the first when it was a black republican
and ben you know there seems to be a
double standard in this country when it
comes to conservatives
well of course i mean if larry elder
were a democrat we know it would have
been front page news there had been talk
about how this white woman throwing an
egg at a black man was just evidence
that nothing has changed over the past
150 years but because larry's a
republican and larry is a conservative
libertarian this means that larry's the
actual white supremacist according to
op-ed writers for the los angeles times
and the woman who is throwing eggs at
him while wearing a gorilla mask is an
anti-racism activist it's it's very
strange how none of the standards seem
to hold as soon as the target is a
conservative
do you uh i mean if larry elder uh larry
elder is leading amongst the 40 plus who
are trying to be there should he be
recalled
but are you amazed at 70 plus million
dollars that poured in the president the
vice president coming into campaign
elizabeth warren are they getting
panicked
and they're certainly scared i mean
gavin newsom has poured 10 times the
amount of money as larry has into this
campaign to prevent himself from being
recalled in a state that is entirely
democratic remember there is a super
majority in the legislature for
democrats it's essentially a one-party
state and now gavin newsom is in danger
of being recalled which just
demonstrates how a guy who is widely
perceived as a possible presidential
nominee in the future has now collapsed
in on himself like a dying star because
he's been such a poor governor of the
state and all of the bad governance over
the past 10 years the same stuff that
drove me and my company out of the state
is now coming back to haunt the
democrats so ben there's a whistleblower
inside google that's reportedly saying
they're undergoing anti-racism training
white supremacy training and um or to to
how to prevent being a white supremacist
it features you at the base of this
pyramid it's called the white supremacy
pyramid features you at the base before
it works its way up to different
individuals what is your reaction to
this
it's pathetic that the most powerful
company on planet earth because google
is the most powerful company on planet
earth in terms of informational
dissemination is purveying
misinformation and lies to its own
employees and it's just demonstrative of
the fact that corporations have gone
woke because they are filled with
cowards or are afraid of the radical
left because there is nothing remotely
remotely related to reality in this
presentation i'm an orthodox jew i've
been extraordinarily outspoken against
white supremacy to the point where the
fbi had to arrest somebody two years ago
for threatening my family a white
supremacist
nonetheless google pushing this kind of
stuff just demonstrates what utter
yellow-bellied cowards they are it's
unbelievable well ben have you known
okay so that's what they're doing with
their training of their employees but
when it comes to google the search
engine has their algorithm impacted you
or your business
uh well it sort of depends on the timing
so there have been problems with google
in the past where the way that their
search algorithm works is that results
that are unflattering to conservatives
come up pretty regularly or they had a
google fact check for a while that was
specifically directed only against
conservative outlets not just mine but
but others like the daily caller or
breitbart we do have to cope with this
from time to time and none of that is is
really a surprise to anybody on the
right side of the aisle all right ben uh
best of luck uh we'll see how this goes
and again we're all vaccinated you're
vaccinated but finding people demanding
and berating unvaccinated is un-american
and uh there's going to be legal action
ben shapiro thanks so much
thank you thanks ben